ça vous plaît comme avocat bien sûr que
c'est 90 c'est sous la pluie et dans un
sol boueux que les premiers tilleuls du
domaine de marly ont été replantés jadis
résidence du roi louis xiv le domaine de
marly fut rachetée en 1811 par napoléon
depuis 2009 le site appartient au
château de versailles s'étaler descend
de la grille royale ce qui est l'arrivée
depuis versailles pour les cortèges
royaux et descend jusqu'au pavillon du
roi et donc ces deux grands murs qui ont
été construits la retiennent
complètement les collines de part et
d'autre trois mètres 32 auteurs quand
même des murs de deux mètres d'épaisseur
construit dès l'origine avec cette
fonction de soutènement et des arbres
pousser sans contrôle
donc ils ont atteint des hauteurs que
vous voyez autour de nous de les racines
dégrader les murs de soutènement et il y
avait en plus un risque avec des coups
de vent ou les où la chute des arbres
arrachés complètement le mur ajoutez à
cela la tempête de 99 qui avait dévasté
les crêtes de marly en emportant 1500
arbres aucun chantier de remise en état
n'avait été entrepris avant aujourd'hui
première étape la campagne d'abattage
nous en avons l'an dernier a battu 750
quand je parle d'arbres je ne parle pas
de jeunes végétaux je parle d'un massif
donc c'était une campagne extrêmement
difficile je dirais senti mentalement
parce que nous aimons les arbres 222
tilleuls seront replantés le long de
l'allée royale selon les plans de louis
xiv pour une restitution parfaite nous
pourrons voir le gazon et les premiers
arbres avec quelques bourgeons au
printemps prochain et donc ce sera aussi
un hommage à le nôtre que de faire
revivre cette partie là du parc
le château lancera une campagne
d'adoption des tilleuls plantés le
public pour ainsi parrainé 1 ap
moyennant la somme de 1000 euros pour
l'automne 2012 1500 végétaux
supplémentaires seront introduits dans
le parc de marly de même à l'automne
objectif une abominable et 2014 on peut
dire que leur part comparé les sera
agréable dans 15 20 ans beau dans trente
ou quarante ans est superbe dans un
siècle
mais les équipes de versailles plantes
pour l'avenir et la postérité